hey guys it's 7e I'm here with some
belly busting bikini ready quick fix
tips I read off some randoms blog you're
gonna love them and I'm back to debunk
those tips today we're gonna be covering
how to burn belly fat the flash 4031
2014 - I'm not gonna do that first up a
tutorial on why'd you have belly fat and
we all know it's for all the gluten and
dairy and on the lack of Chi and
cleanses you've been doing sorry Debbie
the truth is a lot less sexy than you
probably want to believe gaining weight
here is usually a result of just gaining
weight in general and yes some people
have more like a bottom heavy hair shape
and some people have a rounder apple
middle shape but that's just genetics
study deal with them that's okay we're
gonna burn that fat anyway both [ __ ]
bigger boobs and ass hashtag we like
Barbie good luck with that
Thanks cutting all the sugar and carbs
especially fruits do not touch the fruit
pay io for life
sure eating a ton of sugar and heavily
refined carbs will pack a caloric load
and spike your insulin levels which may
lead to weight gain and potentially some
belly fat gain but an excess if anything
is gonna tip the scale as for fruit
fruit contains the sugar fructose which
actually once that he did fine led to
belly fat gain however the researchers
were not actually studying old fruit old
fruit contains fiber and water and other
sugars like glucose vitamins minerals
antioxidants so much good stuff that
wasn't accounted for Plus you'd have to
eat like 1.5 kilograms of apples to get
the same clinical effect and unless
you're feeling the banana girl that's
probably not gonna happen another study
showed that an excess of any kind of
sugar fructose sucrose or glucose lead
to weight gain in general bottom line
guys fruits and carbs are not the sole
culprit of your belly fat but of course
drinking a lot of low fiber pops or
juices will spike that insulin level and
path of caloric load which may lead to
weight gain in general take shots at
cooking oil to get shredded
it's so cleansing it just burns the fat
right off you even if you're to just
drink coconut oil all day you'd get
skinny super fast oh that is so gross
okay guys let's get this straight
coconut oil is loaded with medium chain
triglycerides or ncts which research
suggests are maybe more satiating than
other saturated fats and potentially are
not as easily stored as fat there are
actually some small studies out there
that suggest that medium chain
triglycerides may be useful for weight
loss and belly fat loss in general but
the results in humans have been mixed at
best it's also important to note that
coconut oil is not pure MCT so it's
really hard to know exactly how much
you'd have to consume to see any impact
and whether or not drinking all those
calories through oil would offset any of
the belly busting benefits bottom line
you can try swapping out your regular
cooking oil for a coconut oil if you
like the flavor but do not go drinking
this stuff expecting it to burn away
that belly fat do 20,000 sit-ups every
day before bed so you can whittle your
medal without losing your booze yeah
guys any trainer will tell you that spot
reduction or getting rid of just that
little piece of Pudge on your belly
gonna work actually research showed that
doing daily ab exercises resulted in
zero change to your weight or waist
circumference if you want that six-pack
you've actually got a build muscle
through exercise and proper diet and
then lose the fat on top of it so they
can actually see that definition
having said that a strong core is so
important for just general health but if
the reason for your planks and your
sit-ups all day is to get that washboard
abs look you should probably try
switching things up
just saying what the hell Abbi but what
kind of cleanse are we supposed to do to
get shredded I know you don't like to
hear this Debbie but if you want to lose
belly fat you really kind of just gotta
look at the bigger picture and think
about losing weight and fat in general
so I recommend a diet high in fiber and
protein to promote satiety daily
exercises with weight training and some
cardio like example high intensity
interval training managing your stress
and getting your sleeve ebb or you can
just keep doing crunches as a lot of
them apples that's a lot of apples how
do you like them apples that's a lot of
apples